I hope somehow I'm in Focus now what we
set this all up I forgot about the
Talking part hello
look I'm a woman that drinks out of a
tumbler now what's next a car I can do
anything now and I choose to do nothing
so I wanted to make a video to just say
hey and update you because last time we
chatted it got pretty serious I'm
folding my hands on my desk like a good
little school girl so if you are not
caught up on this little corner of the
internet first of all does anyone have a
Swiffer because this is all covered in
dust over here so the last time we
chatted I just casually mentioned that I
had breast cancer which is still true uh
unfortunately you responded so amazingly
like I just kept saying it floored me
which it did physically because right
after I announced breast cancer I got
covered yeah because the universe is the
silly little minx isn't she she's like
Mark Summers
given me a physical challenge aren't you
I dropped the fat turd in your lap
last time and I wanted to come back with
um I don't know to offer like a towel or
something and just give you a little
update on where we're at so I'm gonna be
starting chemo hopefully in a couple
weeks there's a couple things I gotta
get done first and then it begins so I'm
in this fun little liminal space and an
in-between space no one tells you how to
be in this situation I'm in like a foyer
metaphorically speaking about to enter
what might be a bit of a haunted house
but I'm doing really well all things
considered I am getting a pimple on my
neck though that's new God I feel so
capable with my big girl bottle so what
do I do with this in between time great
question I don't know and so we're just
sort of vibing
sort of preparing and by preparing I
mean I am doing little to absolutely no
research on cancer I feel like this is a
moment that truly clarifies who you are
as a person and I am not much of a
prepper I'm in a good space mentally
which if I wasn't aware of how much work
I have been doing on my brain would be
very surprising I've been doing a lot of
therapy for the last year and wow it's
really paying off right now in this
moment where things have been really
flipped upside down that part makes me
feel very assured confident she says
with a furrowed brow like I do mean that
this universe is a silly little mix
because the timing of this is
um
pretty great I finished graduate school
Ellie and I already got married I was
kind of and have been really like
gearing up for like I want to make
content again I think but I'm a little
nervous and scared of it how do we do it
and then knock knock who's there breast
cancer breast cancer who
I'm in your left tit but now I'm in this
space where I'm just eager to get it
going you know time in this moment has
been moving very slow it gets moving the
way that silly putty stretches my
fashion however in this period of time
has really found itself I am Adam
Sandler core and I think honestly that
was where the trajectory of my fashion
life was headed regardless of this
breast cancer style icon truly I don't
know why I didn't make the connection
sooner in my life but that's where we're
going it looks like he just survived a
house fire effortless everything is
comfortable all the time sweats and
stretch those are the materials that I
want my body to be in and I feel really
good about it oh just lovely what else
is going on oh I'm writing a third book
I think maybe I've said this before
maybe I didn't I'm writing a third book
it is going slow I am distracted Baby by
me saying it to you that will encourage
me it's gonna be unlike anything I ever
written before it's going to be a really
reflective piece on like 15 years of
content creation and my life and my
psychology and uh I think I'm avoiding
it because that's a lot to look at I
think there's a lot to mine there I just
have to remember
things so there will be a lot of inner
deep Dives over the next year what else
is going on oh I'm not a science person
never have been a science person I don't
know that this experience will make me a
science person I appreciate science the
same way I appreciate a microwave don't
know how it [__] works but I'm really
glad it does so I haven't been prepping
by like looking up the science of all of
this I instead of been prepping by
buying some cute things oh do you want a
pre-chemo haul
genre if you had told me from 10 years
ago that eventually I've been doing a
pre-chemo haul video I might have
believed you because everything about
the internet was unbelievable at 10
years ago still is let's show you some
of the things I bought uh for chemo how
about that oh
cute it's not dark it's fun it's not
dark it's fun a friend of a friend
recommended some things and if there's
anything else that you know of and want
to recommend please do lidocaine numbing
cream ocean for our Port so it doesn't
get all ouchy ouchy gingens ginger candy
what is on the front of this look at
that [__] it's a piece of Ginger eating
a ginger candy the cannibalism his name
is Mr knobs it's hard work being the
mascot for the world's best love Ginger
brand when he's tired from photo shoots
and interviews there's nothing Mr knobs
loves more than relaxing with the tasty
Ginger treat has anyone
talk to Mr knobs well other than that
extremely strange Choice I'm pretty
excited about this ginger candy speaking
of candy oh we got Jolly Ranchers I was
told to buy some Jolly Ranchers and when
I'm told to buy candy I buy candy
regardless of what it's for oh speaking
of ports I got Port access sweatshirts
here's my port look at that little guy
when the Band-Aid first came off I was
very freaked out about this new lump in
my arm but now I've gotten used to it
and that is growth but look what I got
another green zip up Hoodie almost
identical to the other one that I was
wearing look except this one can do this
oh whoa I have so much access to my
armpits cute this is just from Amazon if
anyone else out there is looking for
Port access clothing I am leaning into
my full Adam Sandler aesthetic this is
the best I've ever looked so that's it
for this uh pre-chemo haul again if you
have any suggestions on things that
might help please let me know what else
is going on in the meantime I'll still
be doing this might get weird podcast
with memory card that comes out every
Wednesday we also have a patreon
patreon.com just make it weird we do
bonus pods every month we live streams
occasionally I write a kind of
personalized diary blog post every
Friday we have a book club called
barflies bad at reading flies and this
upcoming book that we're reading is my
choice and we're reading the
anthropocene reviewed by John Green
spoilers it's [__] great in a couple
weeks we'll be doing a live stream we're
on our patreon so if you want to sign up
go
go also very curious about keeping you
updated through this process because I
have broken the seal on being very very
vulnerable with all of you so it's hard
to like sew that seal back up kinda well
I think want slash would enjoy uh being
able to share certain parts of it with
you through the process and this was one
of them the before which also you know
I'm feeling good now so I wanted to make
a video that is in good spirits but I
also know that shit's gonna get tough
I'm not disillusioned on this idea of
like la la everything's so fun and I'm
blind and naive to the horrors that
might come in the future no I know all
that shit's coming but for now I just
wanted to show you where I'm at and
where I'm at right now is like pretty
positive it's gonna be okay like I don't
have any reason to not think that and as
someone that is generally
a very deep deep worry about so many
things that haven't happened like I am
truly an expert at creating and
maintaining false narratives that just
like feed my anxiety machine and maybe
because this is so real and not false
that somehow I'm able to like have a
real positive uh relationship with it or
at least like an encouraged relationship
with it I don't know
should that be the end of this video I
will see you the next time I see you
thank you for watching and thank you
again for all the support
um that's it